we're gonna work with this triangle
right here we're going to find the
orthocenter which is where the three
altitudes intersect and that coordinate
is going to be our orthocenter so what
you're doing when you're finding the
orthocenter is you're finding the
altitude of the triangle and you want to
find where those three altitudes
intersects so the altitude is that
perpendicular distance from the vertex
to the opposite side now it doesn't
necessarily you know bisect the opposite
side it's just the the height of the
triangle it's like it triangles like a
mountain if you climb the mountain
somebody says how high above the ground
are you you always want to measure the
perpendicular distance down so for
example here if I wanted to find the
altitude let's say from this vertex I
would have to make a perpendicular like
that to the other side and same thing
over here I'd have to make an altitude
perpendicular distance the other side
where those three altitudes cross that's
going to be the orthocenter
now you don't have to find all three if
you just find two of them they're gonna
where they cross that's gonna be the
common point of intersection called the
point of Concord C and we call that the
orthocenter so let's jump into this
example here now so what I need to do is
I need to find the slope of one of the
sides of the triangle because what we're
gonna do is we're going to find the
opposite reciprocal slope that's going
to be the perpendicular slope so what
we're gonna do here at this point is the
point two five the slope from two five
two five two remember your slope formula
it's y2 minus y1 so 2 minus 5 over x2
minus x1 that's five minus two so you
can see we're getting negative 3 over
positive 3 which is negative 1 now if we
want to find the perpendicular slope we
just have to take the slope flip it over
and make it the opposite so that would
make this a positive one so that's the
slope of this line right here will just
write slope of negative one but this is
gonna be a positive one which is going
to be the perpendicular slope we know
that the line is going to go through the
point zero one so if we were to draw
this line here you can see that the
y-intercept is going to be one and it's
going to have a slope of 1 so our
equation is y equals 1 X plus 1 so
that's going to look something like
let's see up 1 over 1 up 1 over 1
up 1 over 1 etc so it's gonna look
something like that my diagram is not
perfect but that's the basic idea there
now let's go ahead and find the altitude
from this point to this opposite side
here so we want to find the slope of
this line so I'm going to do y2 minus y1
which is 2 minus 1 and x2 minus x1 which
is going to give us 5 minus 0 so that
gives us 1/5 now the perpendicular slope
is going to be negative 5 because I'm
flipping that over making it the
opposite sign and here you can see it's
going through the 0.25 so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to use the
point-slope form Y minus y1 equals M
times X minus x1 we know that the slope
is negative 5 it goes through the point
2 5 so X minus 2y minus 5 and we can
simplify this a little bit by
distributing the negative 5 that's going
to give us Y minus 5 equals negative 5 X
plus 10 plus 10 and if I add 5 to both
sides we get negative 5x plus 15 okay so
now you can see we've got two equations
here y equals 1 X plus 1 and y equals
negative 5 X plus 15 we just have to
find the point of intersection of these
two lines so what we need to do here is
we need to do a substitution y equals 1
X plus 1 I'm going to put that in place
of Y here so we have 1 X plus 1 equals
negative 5 X plus 15 if I add 5x to both
sides that gives us 6x and if I subtract
1 from both sides that gives us 14 and
if I divide by 6 x equals 14 6 which
equals 7/3 if you reduce now if I take
the 7/3 and I put it back into either
one of these equations I'll just put it
into this one here we have 7/3 plus one
which one is really like 3 over 3 so
that's going to be 10 thirds so that
means the y-coordinate is 10 thirds so
our point of intersection is 7/3 , 10
thirds and let's just double-check here
so here we said this had a slope of
negative 5 so we're going down 5 1/2
three four five over one so this line
should look something like that okay and
so it looks like they should be crossing
right there 7/3 is like two and
one-third so two and one-third ten
thirds is like three and a third that's
one two three and a third yep looks like
it matches pretty closely so my diagram
is pretty good here so that's again how
you find the orthocenter algebraically